[Music]
well as fremont is back in full swing
for the second time since the pandemic
folks are making their way downtown to
enjoy tonight's festivities jeremy j
ford is there at fremont as people get
ready for tonight's experience
people are definitely starting to funnel
in i spoke with folks about why they've
chosen to spend their fourth of july on
fremont i like this better than the
strip tusta perkins is in town visiting
from michigan she tells me so far she's
been enjoying the fremont experience i
got here
thursday evening
on the red eye so the entertainment on
the stages
i went and got the best slice of pizza
ever oh the zip lining i've chickened
out and for tori gillespie she's just
happy to feel normal again people not
wearing masks so you get to be a little
more personal you get to see people's
faces again so that's a good thing
especially for local joe mcguire who's
glad to be able to come down and enjoy
the day with his in-laws long awaited
everybody's been waiting to get out and
i think they're having the chance now
it's amazing tonight along with
fireworks folks will get to experience
free concerts from groups such as the
nitty gritty band mackenzie porter and
molly hatchet jeremy j ford live local
now